a breakthrough on immigration a big
meeting today at the White House between
President Trump and leaders of Congress
on both sides of the aisle the American
people got to witness this one and it
was pretty extraordinary the president
allowed cameras to roll for more than 45
minutes as he and lawmakers negotiated
how best to reach an immigration deal
he's now open to an agreement coming in
two phases first addressing young
immigrants and border security with
broader issues to be settled later what
about a clean daca bill now and with a
commitment that we go into a
comprehensive immigration reform
procedure I think that's basically what
dick is saying we're gonna come out with
daca we're gonna do daca and then we can
start immediately on the Phase two which
would be comprehensive I think the
president thinks the legislation should
be a bill of love and offer to take any
heat for blow back set to come 62% of
the Trump voters support a pathway to
citizenship for the doctor kids if you
have strong borders you have created a
opportunity to hear mr. president and
you need to close the deal if we do this
properly daca you're not so far away
from comprehensive immigration reform
and if you want to take it that further
step I'll take the heat I don't care I
don't care I'll take all the heat you
want to give me and I'll take the heat
off both the Democrats and the
Republicans my whole life has been heat
I like heat in a certain way the heat
there is so one thing he's not willing
to compromise on
after you need it so you would John you
need the wall I mean it's wonderful I'd
love not to build the wall but you need
the wall and I will tell you this the
ice officers and the Border Patrol
agents I had them just recently up they
say if you don't have the wall you know
in certain areas obviously that aren't
protected by nature if you don't have
the wall you cannot have security just
can't have it it doesn't work all right
did you love it day days like the wall
across this is absolutely fascinating
and I thought to say that in being in DC
a lot of meetings are like that behind
the scenes and then afterwards both
sides go to their own cameras and
microphones or they take turns and
they're actually much more partisan and
they're playing to their base and what
this did was basically it was like
watching a city council meeting on local
access television but you're actually in
the Cabinet Room with the President and
a bipartisan lawmakers who did not know
that this was going to happen and what I
thought was interesting is that everyone
actually was there and knew what they
were talking about one thing Dianne
Feinstein tried to do I thought was
pretty smart and strategic is she
suggests is why don't we just do a clean
dhaka bill the president like yeah
that's great and then McCarthy very
subtly says exa cuz that wouldn't
include security we need security and so
it's a little risky to be openly
negotiating like that but I thought
amazingly refreshing also I think that a
lot of the hardliners when it comes
especially to dreamers and daca have
backed off but above the fold front-page
story on USA Today included three quotes
on the front page from far I would say
pretty hardline immigration group saying
if we need to do amnesty for children
who were brought here illegally and it's
not their fault Congress won't have any
problem from us so the president is
really actually at this opportunity
where he could do something and what
Lindsey Graham was saying is that your
voters actually want you to do this but
we're gonna need you to take the heat
the president says he's willing to do so
if the right wants to come after us in
primary us because we're gonna vote for
something that makes actual common sense
it's a far cry from where we were on the
campaign trail when it comes to
immigration but I think that if you can
get to a good solution let political
bygones be bygones and just get it done
all right Jesse the wall very stable
is out there table I like boardroom
Trump almost as much as I like rally
Trump the boardroom Trump is good this
is he also used this line when he said
fire in fury so when he goes like this I
think he's everything's under control
he's kind of like the martini that gets
everybody talking he drove a lot of
momentum at that meeting I've never seen
so much bipartisanship Dana says it's
always behind closed doors I've never
seen that kind of wheeling and dealing
among both sides like that ever before
it was an incredible scene to watch the
the cornerstone of the deal is chain
migration lottery the wall and
merit-based that's what Trump wants the
left wants the daka they want the clean
daca vote Trump almost fell for it and
then got rescued well you say whoa we're
not gonna do the daca deal unless we
have some border security the wall will
be built the chain migration is
ridiculous if we want to hire someone
from HR we don't call kg and say you
know is your uncle in HR that's not how
we do it I don't know why America does
it like that and then the lottery
America is not a roulette table I don't
know why we're playing chance with our
immigration system we should use our
brains and then merit-based he said
that's what Canada does I thought the
Liberals loved Canada we want to emulate
their health care system let's emulate
their immigration system too but who
knows III think the Democrats are
squirrely if they do get anything clean
I don't trust that they're gonna commit
to merit lottery or the wall that's why
you got to do it all at once so it's a
risky deal like but Trump said he's
ready to take the heat
he loves heat he loves it loves as much
as the wall okay so Juan what did you
make of this in terms you know the
optics that he's actually showing giving
the American people a front row seat to
how these negotiations go and also kind
of like calling out people like what are
they supportive of what are they not
supportive and also probably showcasing
his intelligence and deal-making skills
yes his genius stability so I think this
is something that's been evident I've
written about this last month but it's
pretty evident that Donald Trump has
opened the door to a deal a
comprehensive deal because guess what
he's the one that said March is a
deadline for the dreamers that to have a
deal and said to the
Kratts let's make a deal but he's been
talking in hard terms just as Jessie was
suggesting about the wall about chain
migration and these things the wall is
just not gonna happen I mean not only
the Democrats not in the mood for
because they think it's ridiculous but
the dreamers have been if you recall
attacking Nancy Pelosi as she was
speaking as AM Cisco and say we're not a
bargaining chip why are you doing this
but of course they held off in December
now we have it front and center the key
here is that Trump wants a deal he says
what we have in common is both sides
want a deal the problem in dealing with
Donald Trump the great businessman
negotiator is when you come to the
nitty-gritty when you come to the fine
points he's lacking he doesn't know the
time he just knows we want a deal so
let's make a deal but now the problem
has been remember the problem going back
to george w bush in oh six the problem
coming forward with obama and the gang
of eight i think that was in fifteen if
i'm right
or sixteen is that you get the far-right
talk show people saying oh my god this
is amnesty this is amnesty if you want
to come in this country you should get
to the back of the line these people
should all be thrown out like you're
going to throw 12 million people out and
then they say oh this this just a matter
of law it's a matter of law they broke
the law there are bad people you know
it's just it the the conversation
devolve and I think that's what Trump is
gonna have to experience he says he'll
take the heat but even for a stable
genius Jesse it's gonna be a lot of heat
coming from the right oh he loves it is
that what he does whole life long so
well I'm all for it because I think he'd
be taking heat principally from the
freedom caucus and and and the sean
Haley Nixon goes to China only Trump can
do it we had an immigration plan with
love and he can get away with saying
something like that because he's talked
about kicking out all the bad hombre
yeah look he just kicked out right now
you got 200,000 el Salvadorans that who
were here as a matter of a voucher some
kind of benefit because of the chaos in
El Salvador and then he's lied the same
standard to the Haitians the Nicaraguans
he is alienated just about everybody
south of the border and I don't know if
now he's willing to alienate his hard
right
supporters okay let's not alienate Gregg
on our border I was just about to go to
another show
you're that versatile exactly I loved it
when he called it a bill of love because
that explosion you heard afterward with
Ann Coulter's head Trump is gonna make a
deal you elected a deal maker and he's
he's working the assumption that if
you're for Trump you will accept any
kind of Trump there is I happen to
believe he's right because when you saw
when you saw today and I don't think you
can under underplay what you saw today
what you saw today was something no
president really is done this is the
most transparent presidency you will
ever see I mean well I can't say that
because we haven't seen what's gonna
happen next when they're robots running
our country but he's a human cannonball
he jumps in makes the loudest noise and
the biggest splash and then the pool
settles and then he figures out
something that everyone can agree to
disagree on or agree not to do or to do
he figures out the deal but he gets in
there and he makes the noise this was a
response in my opinion to the book I
said I was saying and and the thing is a
lot of people are saying that as a
negative
no it wasn't respond it was a great
response think about the think about
this comparison all right because this
is the bigger story here the media is
chasing a mental health fantasy right
now they're chasing a mental health
fantasy meanwhile Trump is chasing a
mental health reality today he expanded
coverage for veterans for mental health
because of the rise in suicides this is
due to lower suicide rates so while the
despicable media is believing in some
baddie doctor who basically fell off the
face of the earth after calling him a
danger to society and now she's walking
it back what's her name bandy I can't
think of her name he's out there trying
to help and save lives that is an
amazing contrast but again you got to go
back to this meeting that was really
everybody who watched it was transfixed
and it was pretty funny watching other
networks admit like this is this is sin
this is something good and I'm also I
have to say I'm really getting tired of
hearing the word dreamers we're all
dreamers alright there's no dreamer
privilege here just because your
specific person doesn't make you a
dreamer everybody in the United States
is a dreamer so stop calling a specific
group dreamer
that's dreamer privilege wait a second
what are you saying because these are
people who understand what it is want
what it is it's a way of trying to
separate it so that these people are
disadvantaged and unique but the rest of
us are all bad people
no we're all dreamers I'm not about
everybody who wants strong enforcement
of the border is somehow hateful and
evil
run the tape we have the videotape but
I'm saying most Democrats oppose the
wall because they see it as redundant
and a waste of money because we have the
Democrats as a waste of money
okay come on all right I hear the
rhetoric but I'm gonna study some
rhetoric we have put more boots on the
ground on the border we have put drones
in the air we put electronic sensors we
have a better system and with the moment
net migration is zero so what you get
for the people you don't want to call
the dreamers there's sixty two percent
of America's like the Clinton Global
Initiative you always had to say well
they do good work but I think it's time
to retire that I think what you're gonna
see is enhanced border security and a
pathway to citizenship together because
that's what Trump is gonna do and right
now the shrink who said he was unstable
is shrinking right now because they're
people that are looking really small are
the people who were talking about
instability on other networks it came in
late but to finish strong